-How it works is you're going to
hit this button here,
which really works.
It activates the opinion topic
generator.
It will land on a random topic
that relates to
this time of year.
Whatever it is, you have to give
your opinion on it.
-Knee jerk?
-Yep. First thing.
Doesn't have to be prepared.
Nothing.
You ready?
-Okay. Yep.
-Go ahead.
[ Musical beeping plays ]
-Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer.
-Oh. You know what?
This is what pisses me off
about that.
No, but for real, okay so
they're mean to him
and there's a foggy night.
I guess this is the first time
it's ever happened.
And so Santa puts him in front,
I'm assuming,
and he lights the way.
And then they go, "then all the
reindeer loved him,
and they shouted out with glee,
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer,
you'll go down in history."
First off, you don't just erase
the abuse.
And secondly,
"you'll go down in history,"
That's a claim. And fame and
love, I hate to say it,
but fame is not love.
They are very different things.
I have done a lot of work to get
to that conclusion.
And I hope Rudolph
sees a therapist.
[ Bell dings ]
-That's unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I never thought about that.
That is fantastic.
-I've never
thought about it either.
-That's so good. That's the
whole point of the game.
Let's give it another go
over here.
-Okay. All right.
[ Musical beeping plays ]
-Mistletoe. If any decoration
needs to be me too'd,
the mistletoe -- this is the
most -- who the hell?
Like, in what world -- like
walking through a doorway
with another person
weird enough.
I don't need this perverted
garnish over the door.
I don't want to see it.
I don't want to hear about it.
-Oh, my God. I've never --
That's fantastic.
I've never heard you
raise your voice.
-It's an upsetting garnish.
-It's an upsetting, yeah.
Let's do another one.
-Okay. All right.
[ Musical beeping plays ]
-Fingerless gloves.
-Okay.
They seem to be favored by
crooks in movies.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I'm no forensic scientist,
but I would imagine
that it's exactly these parts of
the hand that you want to
cover up if you're a crook.
-There you go.
Listen up, crooks.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to do this all night.
We only have time for one more.
-I love my own thoughts.
[ Laughter ]
-John, you have one more.
-Okay, go.
-Thank you very much.
Here we go.
-yeah.
[ Musical beeping plays ]
-The 2010s. 2010s.
-Oh, they're ending.
-They are, the decade is over.
-Ooh!
[ Audience groans ]
-That's right.
-Well, what a decade.
Here's how I'd sum up the 2010s.
I was going through the airport
and there was a guy
and he was traveling and there
was a woman from TSA.
And they were screaming
at each other.
And she said,
"I wouldn't disrespect you,
if you hadn't disrespected me
in the first place."
And that is the 2010s.
[ Laughter ]
We're trying to figure out who
disrespected who
in the first place and we're
both screaming at each other
and everyone is just trying to
get on their Southwest flight.
-That's fantastic.
That is John Mulaney
right there.